[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'abord j'aimerais savoir combien
d'entre vous sont parrains et bien comme
vous je suis parent en fait je suis une
maman ordinaire maintenant dites moi
combien d'entre vous sont parents d'un
enfant handicapé malades ou différent et
bien comme moi vous êtes probablement
départ ordinaire mais avec un défi
extraordinaire votre défi à vous c'est
peut-être la maladie dégénérative de
votre enfant mon défi un mois si
l'autisme sévère de montrichard laissez
moi vous parler vous raconter son
histoire et en même temps celle de l'ina
de maxence et de quelques autres
dès leur plus tendre enfance était
différent des autres et charles faisait
bouger ses doigts devant ses yeux
maxence faisait une fixation sur les
ventilateurs et li na a perdu tous ses
acquis à l'âge de deux ans aujourd'hui
ce sont de jeunes adultes l'inutile
belle jeune femme qui excelle au jeu
vidéo
maxence est un grand fan de musique
québécoise et charles de randonnée en
forêt mais qu'est-ce qu'ils ont deux
spéciales les personnes autistes
en gros ce qui est difficile pour elle
s'irrite d'établir un contact visuel de
comprendre certains codes sociaux aux
non dits les changements dans leur
environnement sont une grande source
d'anxiété et ils ont souvent des
comportements stéréotypés ou répétitif
un jour de novembre 1999
je suis assise dans le bureau du médecin
avec ce magnifique blondinette ou
bouclés sur les genoux
charles trois ans et demi quand le
médecin et m'annonce ce que j'anticipe
déjà depuis un moment
mon enfant est autiste j'ai perdu pied
mais j'ai fini par me ressaisir pour
faire face au défi le plus important de
la vie très rapidement je me suis heurté
à dos douloureux constat d'abord le
diagnostic arrive avec un cruel manque
de services ils sont toujours le cas
aujourd'hui vingt ans plus tard ensuite
la vie de parents d'enfants différents
sites une longue suite de bataille
dans un premier temps pour obtenir un
diagnostic puis des services spécialisés
ensuite l'inclusion à la garderie à
l'école dans les loisirs les transports
et quand ils arrivent alors j'ai du ltte
les services sociaux professionnels ou
les activités de jour et les services
résidentiels
être parent d'un enfant différent c'est
être constamment en quête de solutions
voici ma famille
les hommes de ma vie comme je me plaît à
les appeler ivement conjointe des 30
dernières années et nos fils antoine
samuel et charles un des grands défis
pour des familles comme nous c'est de ne
pas faire de l'enfant handicapé ou
malades le sens de la famille
mais un membre comme les autres en dépit
de ces grands besoins et un autre grand
défi pour des paras comme nous c'est de
composer avec l'arrivée de l'âge adulte
large où nos enfants quittent le nid
familial pour voler de leurs propres
ailes une étape normale positive mais
encore faut-il que chacun des membres
vivaient dans un milieu épanouissent un
look cisme c'est un grand défi en soi
mais obtenir des services adaptés
c'est un véritable chemin de croix
charles 20 ans il est autiste non
verbale et il nécessite un
accompagnement un pour un alors toutes
les sphères de la vie quotidienne depuis
son départ de la maison familiale lieu
connu trois milieux résidentiels
différent du réseau public et il est en
attente de son quatrième il vit
présentement dans un milieu peu adapté à
ses besoins
mais surtout à ses capacités un milieu
de vie temporaire qui restreint sa
liberté et son autonomie au profit de
sécurité il vit dans une résidence qui
est destiné à des jeunes qui ont un trou
grands du comportement or c'est pas son
corps mais étant donné ces grands
besoins d'encadrement n'est pas de
milieux plus léger tu peux l'accompagner
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'un milieu
de vie non adaptés et ça n'exclut pas le
milieu familial ça a des conséquences
c'est à dire ça favorise l'augmentation
de l'agitation
l'anxiété est inévitablement des
organisations de fil en aiguille on va
voir apparaître des troubles graves du
comportement des problèmes de santé
physique mentale s'est dit coût énorme
pour la société mais c'est pas juste une
question de budget
une question de vies humaines les
personnes autistes peuvent s'épanouir
elle aussi
il faut accepter les personnes qui ont
un handicap avec leurs limites et leur
donner accès aux mêmes conditions de vie
et ont même possibilité développement
que les autres citoyens
olivier c'est un jeune homme adulte
quitte à l'opposé du spectre de
l'autisme est un bon exemple également
d'un milieu de vie mal adapté il vit en
appartement depuis quelques années mais
y'a vraiment la difficulté à se
débrouiller totalement seul à ses
parents exercent une supervision
continue pour s'assurer qu'il prend sa
médication qui prend soin de son hygiène
qui s'alimente bien sa santé et sa
sécurité sont les plus grandes
préoccupations cependant pour ses
parents qui vieillissent s'épuise
mais olivier lui était elle son
indépendance c'est normal si et ses
parents vieillissent alors donc si son
milieu de vie
si son milieu de vie comportait une
légère supervision des technologies de
soutien à l'autonomie et des services
adaptés lui pourrait continuer à vivre
en appartement et ses parents pourraient
souffler un peu les personnes autistes
ressentent les choses de façon déculpe
et que ce soit le bruit la température
le mouvement la lumière les odeurs
imaginer imaginez vous dans une arène
avec les cris les applaudissements
soudain le mouvement sur la glace dans
les estrades
le bruit pour vous et moi c'est
peut-être fatigué mais c'est gérable
pour les postes les personnes autistes
tous ces stimulants sont des agressions
alors imaginez maintenant un milieu de
vie
qui comporterait six rites en lot
quotidien
alors 8 10 12 personnes dans un
environnement restreint qui parlent
rient cris qui bouge qui courent même
est bien pour eux c'est comme est à
l'aréna stabilité structure
prévisibilité et calme
en gros c'est dessous qui ont besoin des
personnes autistes
c'est dans cette optique le conte
travaille depuis plusieurs années à un
projet d'habitation de novateur espace
vie tsa tsa pour troubles du spectre
autistique est destiné à seize jeunes
adultes un milieu de vie totalement
différent de ce qui existe présentement
où tout est pensé de a à z pour
augmenter l'autonomie l'adaptabilité
mais surtout le bien-être des personnes
autistes dans un bus d'intégration
sociale et participation à la vie
citoyenne
ce qu'on propose c'est de leur offrir
leur chez soi un endroit et où ils vont
pouvoir vivre pour seulement quelques
mois ou quelques années ici et déposent
leurs bagages pour la vie
notre prétention c'est qu'en travaillant
en amont en prévention leur adaptabilité
vous être leur bien-être va être
grandement augmentée et ça c'est toutes
les sociétés qui vont y gagner
prenons notre exemple à tous on vit
probablement dans une maison bien adapté
à nos besoins
on y est confortable quand on rentre à
la maison le soir on décompresse et bien
c'est ce qu'on veut pour les personnes
qui vont habiter ce pass vitesse mais
puisqu'elles sont fortement touchés par
le stress et l'anxiété elles ont besoin
de plus
quand je sois confortable un peu comme
vous et moi un carton ville des choses
intenses on ait besoin de faire
redescendre la pression prendre les
grands moyens pour y arriver en tout cas
est bien ce qu on veut reproduire avec
espace vie tsa c'est l'état de bien-être
qu'on ressent vous et moi
par exemple quand on voit dans un sport
l'ambiance feutrée la luminosité et la
petite musique apaisante les odeurs
rassurez vous n'avez pas construire un
sport mais ce qu'on veut s'y reproduire
un tout cohérent pour qu'il sente bien
dès qu'ils mettent plus les pieds dans
leur chez eux
voici les bases du concept de se passe
vite et ça pour en faire un milieu de
vie stable structure est prévisible et
calme
on a d'abord besoin d'un environnement
physique qui apaise leur sens hyper
actif ou l'architecturé le design joue
un rôle thérapeutique alors
l'insonorisation la luminosité les
matériaux ou des couleurs l'agencement
des espaces
tout doit être pensé pour atténuer leur
sensibilité à l'environnement que
l'anxiété et en même temps favoriser le
développement de l'autonomie et des
interactions sociales
on a besoin d'un accès à la nature
également le e learning center for
design en angleterre au réaliser une
étude fort intéressante surtout
l'utilisation de la nature et des
jardins extérieurs pour améliorer la
qualité de vie des personnes autistes
alors avec ses différentes sections un
aménagement comme celui ci permet entre
autres des veillées d'essence ou de les
apaiser de socialiser de bouche
relaxé autre élément important de notre
approche
une offre alimentaire de grande qualité
avec des services médicaux intégrer un
encadrement sur mesure par des parts du
personnel formé en autisme et des
environnements réduit en termes de
nombre de personnes qui vivent et qui
interviennent donc notre projet six
appartements supervisés pour des jeunes
qui ont été solides et qui pourrait
vivre en appartement mais qui ont besoin
d'une légère supervision pour y hervé
deux appartements l'apprentissage donc
transitoire pour des jeunes qui ont le
potentiel et la volonté d'aller vivre
éventuellement seul dans la communauté
mais qui ont besoin de faire certains
apprentissages première jouée par
exemple apprendre à cuisiner ou à gérer
un budget et trois grands appartements
sont destinés à des jeunes qui ont des
plus grands besoins d'accompagnement
auquel on va offrir des activités de
jour stimulante
si on ajoute à 1,6 éléments l'eau
l'implication des parents les familles
et des personnes autistes elle-même
tout comme dans notre sport on a un
environnement cohérent où tout est mis
en oeuvre pour favoriser le bien-être
on a la prétention de croire que ce
concept loup peut changer la vie des
personnes autistes et de leurs familles
et on est poli seuls nos partenaires ou
s'ils croient d'ailleurs on est très
heureux de faire équipe avec un groupe
de recherche universitaire pour tester
le modèle et le rendre productive pour
qu'il puisse être utilisé par d'autres
une société bienveillante et inclusive
avec ces personnes handicapées
c'est la société dans laquelle je veux
vivre à laquelle je veux contribuer que
je veux léguer à mes enfants à nos
enfants
un milieu de vie apaisant et
bienveillant leur ouvre la porte vers
une vie riche en réalisations alors
offrons un milieu de vie épanouissant à
des humains différents
merci
[Applaudissements]